Don't you know the life is full of surprises You better realize, better realize
Nobody knows, nobody knows Watching your soul and how your heart works
Nobody knows, nobody cares It's right for you to leave your life, yeah
You can do it right now Oh, you can do it right now
You can do it right now You can do it right now
You can do it right now
Everybody gives you advice, yeah, on how to live your life, how to live your life.
Don't you know that life is full of surprises? You better realize, better realize.
Nobody knows, nobody knows what's in your soul and how your heart works.
Nobody knows, nobody cares. It's up for you to live your life, yeah.
You can do it right now.
Oh, you can do it right now.
Right now.
You can do it right now.
So, ich bin am Start, ich muss gerade nochmal eine Twitternachricht schicken, haben wir
Qualitätsoptionen, ja sehr schön.
Guck mal, ist jetzt die Klimaanlage ausgegangen, ne, der Typ badet, jetzt aber, ich wollte die
nochmal kurz anmachen, weil es eigentlich kalt genug hat, muss man keine Klimaanlage
anmachen.
Hallo Kyo-kun, ist ja Niki eigentlich da, weil heute machen wir ein bisschen das, was
er uns letztens als Arduino Projekt geschickt hat?
Discord steht, ok, dann muss ich mal nachher mal angucken, können wir jetzt schlecht im
Stream machen, weil dann bin ich nicht eingeloggt.
Moin Hexor, unter tbtimbo ist er auch am Start, alles ist so da, so, also wollen wir die Fragen
von gestern aufräumen, ob da irgendwas übrig geblieben ist, MonkaSmo, gucken wir uns noch
an, haben alle schon gesagt, die Themen gestern
wieder teilweise.
Gut, also ich bin, warum genau habe ich einen Tab mit Hyperlul auf?
Wo ist der da, Sin?
Warum habe ich Hyperlul auf?
Ich glaube mich da gar nicht runter zu krollen, was da alles kommt.
Endlich Feierabend, Poggi, ja jetzt wo wir uns an Poggi gewöhnt haben, heißt Poggi
irgendwie wieder Poggers, man versteht es nicht so genau.
Ich glaube Sound ist ein bisschen laut oder, oh Sound, ok, ich glaube Sound ist ein tegel
laut.
Guck mal so, ist in den Hintergrund Gedudel, ist ja eigentlich sonst überhaupt nicht mal
Musik, aber ist deutlich entspannter als irgendwelche Heavy-Metal-Klänge.
Ja, übrigens Leute wisst ihr was ich gerade gesehen habe, ich muss schon wieder was einkaufen,
allerdings jetzt nicht im Stream, und zwar habe ich gesehen, dass es wieder diese Dinger
hier gibt.
Lustigerweise hat mir das auch jemand heute im Stream als Kommentar reingeschrieben, ob
ich die schon gesehen habe, und ja die habe ich schon gesehen, das sind ultra nice Boards
für Selbstbau nass oder für irgendwas was halt ein bisschen mehr Power als den Raspberry
braucht, am besten den x86.
Was ist das für eine Leidungsdistribution?
Immer Ed Wupplos dabei schreiben, dass ich es nicht übersehe.
Das ist Manjaro, es wird öfters gefragt, wie ihr seht, das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM als
Window-Manager.
Gucken wir mal, ob es Updates gibt, Updates, na ob ich das jetzt machen soll?
Normalerweise ist es unter Artstellungs kein Problem, da kannst du auch einfach mal 4G
Updates machen, easy.
Wir machen jetzt mal Updates, das macht unter Artstellungs eigentlich normalerweise nichts,
und Manjaro hat noch mal extra Repos dazwischen, dass die Sachen noch ein bisschen stabiler
sind.
Aber wir können jetzt mal einen Vorteil ausnutzen von VMWare, da bin ich jetzt blöd, wir machen
einfach den Snapshot, und wenn es nicht mehr geht, revertieren wir den Snapshot, überhaupt
kein Ding.
Du hast Manjaro KDE, ja KDE ist nicht meins, Snapshot während des Updates, egal, ich kann
immer noch Snapshot restoren und dann canceln, alles kein Ding, alles Eats, alles Eats, und
wenn es kaputt geht, das ist nur eine VM, wir können ohne Probleme einfach eine neue
Formel machen, die alte Platte dranhängen, und die wichtigsten Sachen runterziehen, da
was im Eimer verzeichnet ist, das sind ja bloß ein paar Dateien.
Du bist gerade in der Umgewöhnungsphase zu E3, ja ich dachte E3 ist wirklich ultra nice,
also E3 ist wirklich, ich hab's am Anfang selbst nicht für möglich gehalten, aber
die Bedienung unter E3 ist einfach im Vergleich zu Fenster basierten, Fenster basierten Window
Managern, ja ok, ich weiß in Window Manager ist ein Window drin, aber das heißt halt
nur mal so, aber im Vergleich zu Fenster basierten Window Managern ist E3 einfach sehr angenehm.
Drei beste, oh Q-Chat ist angesagt, oh, ja ich weiß, dass es im Filesystem installiert,
ich hab's ja auch, warum sollte das auch nicht im Filesystem, im Filesystem natürlich existiert
das im Filesystem, ich hab's doch laufen, hab's doch laufen, na klar läuft das, soll
ich's vielleicht mal stoppen, naja ist gut, ups, naja, ach oder stört er sich dran, das
ist den Ordner, sag mal was spackt meine Tastatur grad so rum, was denn, sind die am Start,
warum, was ist mit meiner Tastatur los, jetzt wieder, ok, Udo, ja wie oft ich schon Udo,
wie oft ich schon Udo geschrieben hab anstatt Sudo und das lustige ist eigentlich hab ich
immer Sudo auf Underscore alias, weil man braucht man für sonst nix und ist praktisch,
was ist Snap, das ist, das ist ein Paket, kein Paketmanager, ja doch ein bisschen so
was wie ein Paketmanager, bloß für fix und fertige Container, die man einfach installieren
kann, die schon fertig gepackaged sind, warum kann ich nicht updaten, kann ich updaten,
weil er sagt slash Snap exist, ja und who cares, dass slash Snap exist, seh was wir jetzt
machen, was das da, guck noch mal ob er Probleme hat und wenn er immer noch nicht will, das
geht ja schneller, weil er hat schon alles runter geladen, sowas wie Docker, ja bloß
das ist eher eigene, komplette Betriebssysteme sind halt bis auf den Kern als Docker, Docker
ist halt immer nur das einzelne Programm, aber wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen, YOLO,
YOLO, es ist eher ein eigenes Betriebssystem immer drunter als anstatt wie bei Docker
die ganze Einwendung, einfach force drüber bügeln, wisst ihr, schon funktioniert und
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch, ja ja es darf nicht rum, sondern wahrscheinlich gibt es
auch überhaupt keine Probleme, mit dem Inhalt, nö, ist immer noch alles da, oh man, du baust
ein ganz schön Livestream Streak auf, ja das stimmt, Force man merkt, dass Max mal so vergewaltigt,
Force muss, ey wenn es nicht geht und das Ding Force Parameter hat, einfach bam Force,
so ist, die einzige Sache, wo ich immer davon abrate Force zu machen ist der da, git push
plop master Force oder git push prod Force oder so, da sag ich allen immer bei mir auf
der Arbeit, Leute, wenn ihr pusht, dann macht es nicht defaultmäßig mit Force, das wollt
ihr eigentlich gar nicht, weil manche Leute sind super super mutig, YOLO und super YOLO
bei uns, die machen sowas hier, geht jetzt nicht, ich bin kein Git Repo, das ist echt
der YOLO Modus, was das macht ist, das pusht, ich, wobei ich glaub, ich glaub, ich glaub
man muss den Remote angeben, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, oder ob man das default Remote
nimmt, zumindest nimmt er, nimmt er im Zweifelsfall, wenn man es verkehrt eingestellt hat, alle
Repo, alle Remotes und alle Branches, die man lokal hat und Force pusht, das ist in
der Regel nicht das, was man haben will, deswegen sag ich allen immer, Leute, schreibt einfach
Remote und Branch aus, TB, Timbo, Mirrors sind lahm, du kannst einfach die Mirrors überprüfen
lassen, du kannst, oah, wie war das, das kann ich, mirror, mirror, mirror, mirror, pack man,
pack mirror, ja, damit kannst du testen lassen, welche, welche Mirrors die schnellsten zu
dir sind und dann abspeichern lassen, bei uns ist es gar nicht erlaubt, Zagornet, ich
hab nen Githook, ich hab nen Githook gebastelt, das eh keiner in die wichtigen Branches pushen
darf, die dürfen alle bloß in ihre Feature Branches pushen und dann den Merchrequest
aufmachen, pack man kann das als GUI, ja, aber wer braucht GUIs, GUIs sind Schwafel,
aber nicht, so, Reboot machen, mal gucken, ob der Kram jetzt Rebootet, aber wenn ich
Rebootet, wenn ich Rebootet, dann geht, dann geht Dings hier, dann geht das, das Pepega
Board geht, geht kaputt, wenn ich Rebootet, ja Leute, ihr könnt jetzt in der Zeit wo
ich Rebootet keine Fragen stellen, weil dann kommen sie nicht an, Rebootet mal, so, ich
hätt vielleicht noch gleich nen Colonel Update mit hinterher schmeißen sollen, ah geht doch,
zünnt den Knaller, mein Imagefont hat sich geupdatet, die Weltkugel sah doch vorher
anders aus oder, die Weltkugel, Leute ohne Scheiß die, alter Windows geh weg, die Weltkugel
sah anders aus davor, der Rest sieht gleich aus, aber das sah anders aus, ich weiß nicht
mal genau wie es aussah, aber es sah auf jeden Fall anders aus, oder bin ich jetzt einfach
nur komplett, äh, wie er im Kopf, das sah anders aus, wir machen noch, wir machen noch
mal schnell nen Colonel Update, wir haben ja Zeit, wir haben ja Zeit, wir machen noch
Colonel Update hinterher, frag mich nicht warum, Colonel Update mache ich irgendwie
am liebsten über das GUI, aber es gibt gar keinen neuen mehr, ok, wir machen noch keinen
Colonel Update, alles gut, alles, die Weltkugel hat sich gedreht, oh, was sollen denn jetzt
die ganzen Flat Earth Leute sagen, die ist schärfer, ok, ah, sie sieht anders aus als
vorher, ich weiß nicht, ok, erstmal wieder das Pepega Board starten, ganz wichtig, Mrs.
FPS, oh Gott, das hab ich doch jetzt schon öfters erzählt, ähm, da ist nix, da ist,
zumindest bis jetzt, oder allgemein ist da nicht allzu viel draus geworden, also wir
haben uns ja sogar zu Weihnachten Dinger geschenkt, sie hat mir nen Torx Schraubenset geschenkt,
ich muss erstmal einen Grill finden, was einem einen Torx Schraubenset schenkt, äh, Schraubenschraubenset,
aber ich bin was zwischenmenschliche Sachen angeht einfach nicht engaged genug, irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, ich hab da nicht so den Zug dahinter immer, wisst ihr wie ich mein, ich
bin da so faul was das angeht, mich um zwischenmenschliche Beziehungen zu kümmern, äh, Net 3, was war das
richtige Projekt, das da, musste ich halt mal forsen, genau, zu viel Aufwand, ne, ich weiß
auch, ich kann das, ich kann das sehr schwer in, äh, in Worte fassen irgendwie, für mich werden zwischenmenschliche
Sachen einfach instant anstrengend, und das heißt noch nicht mal, dass ich die Leute nicht
gar nicht mag oder solches, ich hab da irgendwie keinen Bock großartig drauf, das Zebaro wieder,
so, das PP-Gabort läuft wieder, alles gut, so, gut, wir haben ein paar G-Update gemacht,
alles nice, alles gut, ja, weil ich euch zeigen wollte, es gibt jetzt wieder neue Ultroid H2
Kisten, hab ich gesehen, werden neue Sachen ausgeliefert und zwar ab nächsten Monat, englische
Monatsschreibweise, FTW, ja, und das ist eigentlich das Board, was ich ins Auge gefasst
hab, für mein NAS-Build, weil das hat vier Kerne, ähm, einen vierfach angebundenen
M2-Slot, wo ich wahrscheinlich eine Netzwerkarte rein machen kann, das hatte ich so ins Auge
gefasst, zwei SATA-Anschlüsse, USB 3, also eigentlich alles, was man so haben möchte,
Problem die ganze Zeit war, es war nicht lieferbar, und es brauchen, das ist optimal, das Board
auch nicht, es braucht einen extra, extra komischen random 15 Volt Stromanschluss, und
es hat so einen komischen Formfaktor, der nicht in normale Gehäuse passt, irgendwie
ist das auch nicht so das, und dazu kommt, deswegen werd ich mir wahrscheinlich jetzt
auch keins kaufen, auch wenn ich mir gerade fortan so überlegt hab, ich kauf mir, aber
ich wär's mir nicht kaufen, ähm, weil es kostet auch einfach mal 50 Euro mehr als
die normalen Boards dieser Art, auch wenn es nice ist, was es für Features hat, aber
letztendlich bringt's mir auch nix wirklich, wird doch nicht gekauft, ja yes Leute, wird
doch nicht gekauft, ab letztem Monat, ist das letzter Monat, ich kann mir Englische,
äh, Englische, äh, Juni, Juli, äh, Jun, Juli, Dings, Gedöns, kann ich mir nicht merken,
was da wie genau ist, ich kann mir erst mal den August merken, der Rest ist doch eh, macht
da eh keine Unterschied, und US-Monat, US-Monatschreibweise und verwirrt mich immer, wir hatten heute,
wir hatten heute wieder auf der Arbeit ja auch genau so was, ich hab nach einem, ich hab
nach einem Comment geguckt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das gemacht war, es hat die übelste,
es hat für die übelste Verwirrung gesorgt, ähm, also einer hat gemeint zu ihm, ja das
ist doch, das ist doch schon ewig drin, ne, und dann haben wir irgendwie einen Comment
gefunden vom 2.8., bis wir dann halt rufgekommen sind, erstens, das muss vom 8.2. sein, weil
wir haben ja noch gar nicht August, haben wir für unnötig Verwirrung gesorgt, ey, das
ganze, grad mal gucken, ob ich mein, grad mal schauen, ob ich den Controller richtig
angeschlossen hab, blub, noch mal schauen, ob ich den Controller richtig angeschlossen
hab, aber was ist es, 115200, kann ich mir langsam mal merken, schauen wir mal, nein,
ich hätt's mir nie merken können, ach Moment, doch, das stimmt doch, oder, nein, Secrets
wollen wir nicht öffnen, und zwar ist wieder jeder mein WLAN Passwort, da hab ich eigentlich
keinen Bock drauf, Monitorspeed wollen wir haben, das ist Monitorspeed, können wir gleich
sehen, ne, Monitorspeed ist das Richtige, so Secret mach ich auch mal zu, weil ich will
mein WLAN Passwort nicht leaken, das ist doof, da muss ich mein ganzes WLAN Passwort ändern.
So, okay, also, ich guck mal, ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab, willst du mal ein Social
Update pushen, ja, ich hab 7 Kilo abgenommen, was hältst du eigentlich von DeltaChat, DeltaChat
sagt mir jetzt nichts, es hört sich ein bisschen so an wie das, wo man Modern Warfare 2 spielen
konnte, außer im offiziellen Server, aber das wird wahrscheinlich was ganz anderes
sein, warum musst du das Passwort vom WLAN ändern, naja, wenn man in einem Stream mit
um die 100 Zuschauern sein WLAN Passwort zeigt, wo halt auch die eigenen Geräte drin hängen,
wäre es nicht verkehrt sein WLAN Passwort zu ändern danach, außerdem hat man WLAN so
einen dummen Namen, da gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht so viel in Deutschland, wobei ich hab,
das stimmt nicht, ich hab für den Stream eh einen extra WLAN, das ich danach wieder
wegschmeißen kann, aber ich will es trotzdem nicht zeigen, ich mein, das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar,
wenn ich hier einfach Secret schreibe, ja, das war durch weniger Essen, so siehts aus,
immer noch weniger gegessen, oder immer noch weniger essen, ich hab heute wieder kaum
was gefuttert, das ist so eine Gewöhnungssache irgendwie, ich hab heute morgen zwei Brötchen
gegessen, hab meine Thermoskanne Tee getrunken, ich hab früher nie, da hab ich immer über
die Leute gelacht, die sich immer so Tee mitbringen, hab ich gesagt, ey, sieht so opa-mäßig
aus mit so einer Thermoskanne, und mittlerweile hab ich mir auch so ein Ding eingepackt, zwei
Brötchen, Kanne Tee, und dann erst eben um 17.30 wieder ein bisschen was, das ist einfach
irgendwie eine Gewöhnungssache, wird halt ein bisschen abgenommen, hab ich jetzt nicht
so, dass das schlecht wäre, wenn ich abnehme, ich bin jetzt halt, ich bin ja nicht übertrieben
fett, also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nicht die Treppe hochkomme oder so, aber ein paar
Kilo weniger wären auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht, sick, nee, ich hab nix mehr nachgegessen,
aber nix, mit der Oberkörperfreibild vorm Spiegel, nee, wenn schon, würde ich das so
machen wie Putin, mit der Angel im Fluss, Oberkörperfreie, oder Reiten auf dem Bär,
das wäre eine Bodybuilder-Routine, ja, zwischen abnehmen und wenig essen und noch irgendwie
Bodybuilden ist schon noch ein bisschen was dazwischen, ja, okay, ähm, wo wollen wir
jetzt wieder ewig rumlabern, ich muss jetzt mal anfangen, weil Leute, ich bin übelst
müde, wenn ich jetzt nicht anfange, dann wird das heute wieder nix, dann laber ich
einfach zwei Stunden wieder vor mich hin und es passiert nix, also, was wir heute machen
wollen ist, ähm, meine 3,3 Volt Ultraschall-Sensoren sind da, die sind heute angekommen aus England,
die haben ewig gebraucht, warum auch immer die so ewig gebraucht haben, ich hab die nämlich
extra in England bestellt, dass es schneller geht, aber die haben sich gedacht, gebated,
und zwar ist das ein, ein Sensor mit dem ultra, äh, griffigen, sprächli-, tollen, griffigen
Namen, HCSR04P, oh, wer kennt die nicht, ähm, und wichtig ist, der HCSR04 ist 5 Volt und
der HCSR04P, wär das auch anders sein können, ist 3,3 Volt, sehr gut, Sebaro, aber Sebaro
auf dem, auf dem Discord, ne, also, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall brauchen wir
den da, das ist der allerwichtigste, und noch, also auch wichtig, wir brauchen auch ne Steigerung,
wir brauchen auch MonkaX, was zur Teufel ist das, ähm, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall MonkaS
und MonkaX, und so wie ich den Sebaro kenn, sind natürlich die ganzen Weep-Emotes auch
am Start, dann werd ich mir nach dem Stream mal den Discord angucken, und dann werden
wir das ein bisschen promoten, in den nächsten Streams, genau, wie gesagt, ähm, der Sensor
ist am Start, ich hab ihn hier auf dem Tisch liegen, ich hab auch wieder mein, äh, ESP32
Developer Board am Start, und ich hab's schon angeschlossen, deswegen probier ich das Ganze
mal aus, und das Ziel heute ist folgendes, was ich mal probieren will, ich weiß nicht,
ob der Nicky da ist, weil der Nicky hat letztens, im letzten Stream, oder im vor, vor, vorletzten
Stream, oder so, hat nen Zuschauer, der hieß Nicky, ein Arduino Programm uns gepostet und
hat gesagt, der programmiert noch nicht so lange, und da haben wir uns ein bisschen das
angeguckt, und wir machen heute was recht ähnliches, wir tauschen heute ein paar Sachen per MQTT
aus, MQTT ist ein Message, ähm, Message Queue Protokoll, was sehr leichtgewichtig ist, und
ähm, sich dementsprechend super eignet für Internet of Things Geräte, oder für Sensoren,
die wenig Strom brauchen sollen, beziehungsweise die hauptsächlich, äh, halt ausgeschaltet
sein sollen, und ab und zu mal angehen, genau, MQTT, so, das erste, was wir jetzt machen
müssen, ist, ähm, jetzt hab ich voll Brain Lag, äh, was wollte ich machen, Hyper Brain
Lag, was wollte ich denn machen, äh, ich wollt grad sagen, das erste was wir machen
müssen ist, oh jetzt hab ich vergessen, egal, das erste was wir machen, bis mir das andere
wieder eingefallen ist, wir testen erstmal, ob der neue Ultraschall Sensor überhaupt
funktioniert, Kio Kunt, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, also wir testen erstmal, ob
der Ultraschall Sensor überhaupt funktioniert, das heißt, wir müssen uns erstmal die Pins
merken, Hallo Klärbär, äh, wir müssen uns erstmal die Pins merken, an denen der Ultraschall
Sensor dran ist, das ist GPIO 25 und GPIO 26, das heißt, wir legen uns jetzt mal sowas
an, ähm, wie es auf dem Ultraschall Sensor drauf steht, da steht nämlich drauf, das eine
ist der Trigger Pin, und das ist GPIO 25, muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das richtig ange- der
Orangene, der Orangene ist 26, ups, ich hab einen Trigger Pin und wir haben einen Echo Pin,
und über die Pins können wir den Ultraschall Sensor ansteuern, der Sinn und Zweck von dem
Ultraschall Sensor ist, ähm, ja, genau, gut, dass du fragst, Kio Kunt, also was man mit
so einem Ultraschall Sensor machen kann, außerdem tun die Dinger so, das ist im Prinzip, wie
das so eine Fledermaus macht, ähm, man hat, man hat hier, also was man dann am Ende damit
machen kann, sag ich gleich, dann nur mal so ungefähr wie das Ding funktioniert, ähm,
äh, gut, Strom und Ground ist egal, wichtig ist in dem Fall der Trigger und der Echo Pin,
da ist hier oben quasi ein Lautsprecher und ein Empfänger dran, das Ding sendet Ultraschall
aus, das Ding empfängt Ultraschall, und über den, über die zeitlichen Unterschied zwischen,
zwischen, ähm, senden und empfangen, bzw. wie viel Pulse der wie schnell empfängt,
ja, äh, äh, Schrottler, aber ich hab die bessere Version, ich hab die neue Version
am Start, ich hab die 3,3 Volt Version am Start, die kann man nämlich endlich mal zu
was gebrauchen, die alte Version war Crap, ähm, kann man dann erkennen, wie weit Gegenstände
entfernt sind, das ist sehr praktisch, kann man entweder für Sachen verwenden, wie, ich
hab gesehen, irgendeiner hat nen, nen, nen, irgendwie so nen Autozählsensor gebaut, wie
viele Autos bei ihm vorbeifahren, das ist halt bisschen, bisschen blödsinnig, ähm,
ich werd's verwenden für ob ich Post bekommen habe, also ob beispielsweise in diesem Zeitungsrohr
was drinne ist, oder ob im Briefkasten was drinne ist, das kann man ganz gut damit, ganz
gut damit checken, weil ist der Abstand auf einmal, auf einen Schlag einfach so gut wie
nicht mehr vorhanden, steckt halt was im Briefkasten drinne oder im Zeitungsrohr, wozu man das auch
noch ganz gut verwenden kann, was, was sehr praktisch ist, wenn man, wenn man Wassertank
hat oder isch wie so ne Zisterne oder sowas, oder, oder ne Wassertonne oder, oder irgendwas,
oder, oder ne Tonne an sich irgendwie, und man wissen will, wie voll die ist, das geht
sogar, wenn die Tonne nicht zu dick ist, geht das sogar von außen, da kann man quasi erkennen,
ähm, wenn man, wenn man irgendwie so nen Wasserspeicher hat oder sowas, im Hof oder im Keller oder
irgendwo, und man wissen möchte, wie gefüllt der ist, hängt man sich nen ESP32 dran mit
so nem Ultraschall-Sensor, ha ha ha, Glocks HD, Zisterne, ja, ähm, genau, und da kann
man sehen, wie viel Wasser da drin ist, oder generell wie gefüllt was ist, also das Ding
hat sich jetzt recht praktisch, äh Schrottler, ich glaub die Dinger sind ein bisschen langsam
oder, um damit, um damit, ähm, so Live, Live-Messungen für irgendwelchen fahrenden Roboter und so
zu machen, ich könnt mir vorstellen, die Dinger sind ein bisschen zu, bisschen zu langsam
und die Dinger sind ein bisschen zu eingeschränkt, die, wie breit sie sind, weil, weil sonderlich
breit geht das ganze nicht, also ich hab's ja mit dem alten ausprobiert, ähm, wenn
ich die Hand drüber halte, geht das, wenn ich die Hand ein bisschen schräger weiter
weg halte, geht's schon nicht. Wann Go lang, wann Go lernen geplant ist ja, das wird noch
ein bisschen dauern, also so ganz blind werd ich das nicht machen, ich werd mir schon vorher
mal die ein oder andere Videos angucken und dann machen wir im Stream was, weil so ganz
ohne Ahnung ist ja auch blöd, ja, also ich könnt mir vorstellen für wirklich so Live-Roboter-Geschichten
ist es wirklich ein bisschen blöd, aber für so was wie gucken ob Post da ist, ist das
super, das Ding wacht einmal, keine Ahnung, in 30 Minuten auf, guckt ob was im Briefkasten
drin ist und dann schläft's wieder ein. So, genau, deswegen, wir testen jetzt erstmal
ob der Ultraschall-Sensor überhaupt funktioniert, also das Ding ist an GPIO, oh fuck, jetzt hab
ich, wie rum, 25, so rum, 26, 25, das riecht schon rum, der orangene ist an, orangene ist
an 26 und 26 ist Trigger Pin, ok, nice. Bei allem was nicht direkt vor dem Bot stand
wurde es kompliziert, ja, das hab ich auch schon gemerkt, also die Range von dem Ding,
also vom Winkel her, so, ist nicht sonderlich gut, was im Prinzip bei mir für den Briefkasten
beziehungsweise das Zeitungsrohr egal ist, aber vom Roboter kann ich mir vorstellen
es ist wirklich ätzend. Ok, dann fangen wir mal an, wir klauen uns einfach die Sachen
die wir das letzte Mal für den 5V-Sensor programmiert haben, klauen wir uns einfach
mal, weil, warum sollen wir den Kram nochmal programmieren, wenn wir das schonmal gemacht
haben, ich muss bloß mal gucken wo wir es gespeichert haben, hier vielleicht, ja, genau
da ist der Kram drinnen, bla bla bla bla bla bla, measure distance, das copypasten wir
uns mal, gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an was er genau macht und dann copypasten wir uns
mal das Setup, WLAN können wir auch gleich einschalten, das brauchen wir dann noch, ok,
Setup, ok, Trigger Pin ist auf Output, Echo Pin ist auf Input, Measure Distance haben wir
auch drinnen, dann probieren wir jetzt mal aus ob das funktioniert, Upload und schauen
wir mal was er macht, also das Ding hängt jetzt hier so halb vom Schreibtisch runter,
der sollte auf jeden Fall irgendwas anzeigen, hoch, wo ist jetzt das Problem, hab ich doch
richtig eingestellt, oder hab ich mich wieder vertippt, ja, hab ich mich wieder vertippt,
ja, na, doch gut aus, nochmal Upload, du brauchst echt mal für sowas ne Webcam, wovorzu brauche
ich da ne Webcam, what the fuck, was hat der denn jetzt für Probleme, hat der denn jetzt
für Schmerzen, was, Moment, wo hab ich eben, irgendwo hab ich was verkackt, damit du auch
was sehen kannst, ach so das Board, ja vielleicht muss ich mal überlegen, ich bin jetzt verwirrt,
was hat der denn jetzt auf einmal für Schmerzen, ich resette, ich resette das Ding nochmal kurz,
also wo ist jetzt dein Problem, ok, Andu, ah, ähm, was zum, Moment, 9600, der kann
doch nicht 9600 haben, ne, das Board ist nicht kaputt, ist es doch Monitor Speed, es ist
doch Monitor Speed, ah, jetzt gehts, warum ging das überhaupt dann einmalig, kann mir
das irgendjemand schlüssig erklären, warum ging's, vorhin, wenn ich mich auch verschrieben
hab, ja nice, guck, funktioniert, äh, Moment, wo kommt die Null her, also hier ist jetzt
Sensor, jetzt Richtung Decke, so 180cm, kommt hin, Hand rüber, Hand rüber, 5, Hand weiter
weg, 21, 25, geh jetzt mal langsam ran, 16, 15, 13, 12, also man sieht es funktioniert,
kommt denn die Null, ach, die Null kommt von hier oben, oder, weil, wenn der hier Distance
printen kann, und hier Distance Return, kann das da unten da oben machen, oh, Moment Leute,
ich muss es mal auskommentieren, der wieder verschmerzen hat, äh, Moment, geb ich, geb
ich irgend den Bullshit zurück, kann das sein, Null, ach, was mach ich denn da, Return Distance
kleiner 2, was soll denn, was hab ich denn da getippt, Return Distance kleiner 2, das
gibt True oder False, was, was genau, was hab ich mir dabei jetzt gedacht, kann das
sein, dass ich das hier zeigen wollte, wenn Distance kleiner 2, dann 2, dass ich irgendwie
sowas schreiben wollte, weil das ist totaler Bullshit was ich da mache, das kann überhaupt
nicht funktionieren, ja, jetzt funktioniert es nämlich auch, machen wir, wir machen das
mal einen Ticken schneller, machen wir alle 100 Millisekunden, dann können wir mal gucken,
wie, wie das reagiert, das Ding, also ich mach jetzt die Hand vorbei, zieht man direkt,
so, und so wird es dann ungefähr, wenn einer, wenn einer Post in den Briefkasten schmeißt,
so nach dem Motto hier, ich schmeiß jetzt mal Post ein, das Ding hängt da drin herum,
twice Raspberry, Raspberry Pi Case, Post, zack, Post drin, Post raus, Post drin, Post
raus, wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, ist wie gut ein Ultraschallensensor in einem Metallkasten
funktioniert, aber zumindest merke ich das, wenn da auf einmal was direkt vorm Sensor
ist, ok der Ultraschallensensor funktioniert, das war schon mal nice, hol ne Dose, ich hab
hier, ich hab hier noch irgendwo ne, so ne Raspberry Case was mitgeliefert wird, da könnte
man das mal ausprobieren, ich guck gerade, irgendwie nen, irgendwie nen Metall, ok ich
hab nen Gehäuse, ich hab nen Gehäuse, das könnten wir nehmen, warte mal, das probieren
wir jetzt mal aus, ob wieder sich verhält mit Metall drumrum, die Dinger sind doch nicht
aus Metall, ja das Zeitungsrohr nicht, der Briefkasten selber schon, das Rohr pack ich
das ganz hinten rein, gerade hinten rein, warte mal ich mach mal ne Kiste drüber, Kiste,
es juckt das Teil, es juckt das Teil überhaupt nicht, Kiste weg, Kiste drauf, Kiste weg,
wenn da nur ein Brief drinne ist, naja warte mal wir halten jetzt mal ein Stückchen Papier
dazwischen, Moment, hier Stück Papier, ich mein es ist nicht so, dass es, also meine Hand,
meine Hand auf gleicher Höhe ist ein bisschen weniger, aber das funktioniert wunderbar,
wenn das nicht mit Metall funktioniert, kann man da, du kannst mit, damit könntest du
wahrscheinlich echt ne Fledermaus ärgern mit diesem Ding, das dürfte so auf ähnlicher
Frequenz sein mit Fledermaus, benutzt du Platformer, ja das ist Platformer, ja gerade, ok Distanz
measuren funktioniert, dann probieren wir jetzt mal das aus, was ich schon seit ein
paar Tagen ausprobieren will, wie wir den Mist gescheit Multithreaded kriegen, nicht
weil man es braucht in dem Fall, weil es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das irgendwie die super
krasse Leistung frisst, dass die CPU langweilt sich, aber ich würd kein mal ausprobieren,
wie immer ein ordentlich Multithreaded in so nem ESP32, da hab ich schon ein bisschen
Beispielcode gefunden, und zwar, ehm, eh, pin core, irgendwie so, wie ging das, genau
das hier, das hab ich schon mal rausgesucht im Vorfeld, so macht man anscheinend Multithreading
auf dem ESP32, äh, ja mach mal Void, Setup, Background, Task, muss man nicht immer alles
in Setup rein klatschen, so, so funktioniert das wohl, das heißt, hier geben wir an, was
er ausführen soll, ok, hier geben wir dem Ding nen Name, ein Taskhandle, kann man da
auch Null übergeben, hm, wir probieren jetzt einfach mal, ob man da einfach Null übergeben
kann, braucht kein Taskhandle, das soll bis zum Schluss, bis zum Schluss soll er laufen,
was ist mal wenn eine Fledermaus im Zeitungsrohr ist, ja da hab, da über diesen, äh, besonderen
Fall hab ich mir jetzt noch keine Gedanken gemacht, was ist, wenn eine Fledermaus im
Zeitungsrohr ist, die, die, der geht dann wahrscheinlich so da drinnen, die blickt
überhaupt nicht mehr durch, ok, ähm, und hier muss man ne Funktion angeben, die ausgeführt
werden soll, so, können wir machen, da machen wir mal hier, keine Ahnung, äh, Tests, irgendwas,
einfach zum, dass wir was zum ausführen haben, die führen wir aus, und da drinnen machen
wir nix anderes wie ne Schleife, die uns ausgibt, ähm, ich hab hier auch gerade gesehen, man
kann hier einstellen, man kann auslesen, auf welchem Chor man läuft, dann geben wir das
einfach mal dort aus, und dann machen wir nen Delay, wahrscheinlich ist das überhaupt
nicht der Weg, wie man macht, aber mal testen, wie das ganze funktioniert, so, Setup Background
Task, und den starten wir jetzt mal, Background Task, Upload, oh, oh, oh, oh, was hat er,
was hat er für Schmerzen, Void, oh, wir sind ja im C++ und C-Land, Void, ah, ich glaub,
meine Funktionsparameter stimmen nicht, ich glaub, die Parameter hiervon stimmen nicht,
was braucht das Ding für Parameter, Void-Parameter, ah, egal, da ist wieder was für die C-Fans,
jede Menge Void-Pointers, Void-Pointer beste, IPS Void-Pointer, ähm, so, mal gucken, ob
das jetzt funktioniert, also der müsste jetzt ausgeben, ich laufe auf Chor 0, ja, jede Sekunde,
guckt, auf dem ersten Chor, ach so, wir müssen noch mal gucken, auf was für einem Chor überhaupt
das Standardzeug läuft, ähm, okay, also waren wir hier, Serial, Print, Print, äh, Task,
was wir hier machen, war, äh, Ahnung, Main, so, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt, weil wenn
das jetzt alles im gleichen Chor läuft, wäre ja reichlich sinnlos, ne, passt, also, unsere
Main Loop, Main Thread läuft irgendwie auf 1, auf Chor 1 und das andere, was aktuell
nichts macht, außer, äh, zu Delayen, ähm, läuft auf Chor 0, das ist doch schön, das
heißt, also so Multithreadet man auf einem ESP32, jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch mal
was Sinnvolles machen, das heißt, wir lesen jetzt mal die, ähm, auf dem Hauptthread lesen
wir die, ähm, Werte ein, von dem, von dem Sensor und auf dem zweiten Sensor, connecten
wir uns zu einem öffentlichen MQTT Broker und veröffentlichen mal unsere Sensorwerte,
einfach gucken, wie es funktioniert, ja, also ich, das ist jetzt keine sonderlich sinnvolle
Geschichte, wenn man das mit einem Heimautomatisierungssystem verbindet, dann kann das natürlich schon
sinnvoll sein, ich muss übrigens gerade noch mal was ausprobieren, kann man das nicht
mit irgendwelchen Lambdas machen, die haben doch jetzt auch sowas in C++, also kann man
nicht einfach sagen, ähm, wie viel ist den Tag, so, so, so, irgendwie, achso, ähm, ja
hier muss ich ja noch angeben, drinne, äh, Void, P, oh, waaah, achso, ja gut, weil die
Funktion leer ist, backt da wahrscheinlich rum, works as intended, Format, man kann das
Dokument nicht richtig formatieren, das sieht hässlich aus, Upload, das sah auf jeden Fall
nicht gesund aus gerade, ah ja, ok, jetzt funktioniert's, ok, mit Lambdas funktioniert
das auch, geht eigentlich sowas, Auto, warte, du benutzt in C++ auch die Geschweifenklammer
auf und zu unter den Funktionen, klar, was sollen sie an, das kann sie Funktionen nicht
an, Alter, welches Jahr haben wir, wir haben 2019, es gab doch mittlerweile schon zwei
C++ Standard, ne, ein, ne, es gibt 17 und 17 und und und Z oder sowas gibt's glaub ich,
ne, Z ist der, Z1 ist glaub ich der aktuelle, warum haben die denn, was haben die denn für
den Default, C++ Standard und die 11 oder was, na, ähm, Henu, wenn schon, also meine
Lieblingsschreibweise von Funktionsnamen ist ja eigentlich KebabCase, kennt ihr KebabCase,
KebabCase, CamelCase kennt jeder, kennt aber, kennt ihr KebabCase, KebabCase ist das was
die Javascript Leute gerne machen, das ist eins der wenigen Sachen die mir an Javascript
gefällt, CamelCase kennt jeder, das ist so die Geschichte, wie man das, hauptsächlich
in, sagen wir mal in C Sharp, die mögen eigentlich CamelCase und so eine Mischung aus Camel und
PascalCase, äh, Ruby Leute stehen unglaublich und die, und Python Leute auch, stehen unglaublich
auf SnakeCase und Javascript Leute mögen KebabCase, ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
ganz sicher, warum die Schreibweise KebabCase heißt, aber das werden sie uns bestimmt erklären,
warum hast du das KebabCase, ach was, wegen dem Bindestrich oder was, da werde ich ja nie
drauf gekommen, aber ich mag die Schreibweise, ich mag die KebabCase Schreibweise, darf man,
darf man sowas machen, Discard, Discarden, aha, Discarden darf man, weil wir brauchen
die Parameter nicht, wir haben keine Parameter, ja viele Sprachen sind nicht so scharf auf
Minus, aber Javascript Leute, also wobei, in variablen Namen können das glaube ich
sogar relativ viele, was damit Probleme hat sind alle C-Style Sprachen, die mögen das
glaube ich nicht, also so, ich glaube sowas hier geht nicht, blub blub, weil dann denkt
er du möchtest das minus das rechnen, C-Style Sprachen haben es nicht so mit KebabCase,
aber ich finde KebabCase eigentlich ganz praktisch und hübsch, OPAP auch nicht, ja kann es eigentlich,
so genau, aber mir gefällt es optisch eigentlich ganz gut, wie kriege ich dem Ding jetzt beigebracht,
dass wir einen neueren C++ Standard verwenden wollen, das muss man garantiert irgendwo,
in diese Plattform IO Config reinschreiben, Buildflex, Buildflex gleich C++11, C++14,
hier probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert, ob, funktioniert das, ob, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja meinetwegen auch 17, aber wenn er noch nicht mal 14 frisst, ich will das jetzt umstellen,
aber doch, ich copy paste einfach mal, copy paste beste, achso 14, ich bin
dazu blöd für, so müsste es doch eigentlich funktionieren, was wir gerade machen, wir haben
einen Ultraschallensensor dran, lesen die Daten auf dem einen Core aus und wir wollen mit dem
anderen Core die Daten verschicken, ah nice Link zu Agor und gleich mal ausprobieren,
Ups, warum hatte das jetzt nicht kopiert, jetzt hat das kopiert, warum brauchst du den Ultraschallensensor, um zu gucken, ob ich Post habe und um zu gucken, ob in der Wassertonne genug drin ist,
Buildflex, probieren wir es mal so, all die Musik, ja, und genau der Alex hat recht, warum auch nicht,
genau, Extrascript Pü, warum genau haben die noch mal diese Buildflex Option, wenn sie die nicht richtig auswerten,
ok, Extrascripts, Advanced Scripting, jetzt ist es aber hier abgedreht, Extrascripts, Extrascript Python, ok, mach das jetzt einfach mal so wie es da steht,
Extrascript gleich, ne Scripts, ich hab keine Ahnung was ich da mache, Extrascript gleich Extrascript Pü, wir wollen es ja nicht Post, einfach mal das Pre ausführen, Pre kann man auch davor schreiben,
Aha, Pre Doppelpunkt, das ist aber echt ein bisschen kompliziert, das war es übelst High Quality, Pippe Dance, Pippe Please,
gibt es für den Ultraschall Sensor irgendwie ein wasserdichtes Case, also ich denke mal 1, 2 exakt der Ultraschall Sensor rein passt nicht, es sei denn du druckst dir dasselbe aus, sodass es wasserdicht ist, du kannst dir aber einfach eine ganz kleine IP65 Box kaufen, die ist dann wasserdicht,
ok und jetzt legt man das einfach hier rein oder, Extrascript, Script P, dann fügen wir das mal ein, dann gucken wir was funktioniert,
Huge Pock, alter es funktioniert, WTF, Moment, Standard C++1Z, ist C++1Z gleich 17, ich dachte 1Z ist der ganz neue der noch gar nicht raus ist, oder ist 1Z 17,
Oh, und warum gibt es C++14 und Q++14, machen die wieder extra Wurst, 1Z ist 17 ok, oh das muss ich mal gucken,
Differences, Q++, C++, ok C++17 und Q++17, warum gibt es dann schon wieder unterschiedliche Designs, Differences, ja genau was ist der Unterschied,
Knue Extensions, ach wir machen Knue Extensions, Knue Extensions beste, Knue++17, Knue das ist die Organisation hinter dem Compiler,
ok, das heißt wir können jetzt Auto machen hier an der Stelle, Auto und können wir aber auch den Pointer weglassen, da können wir direkt so machen,
oh das gefällt mir, das ist schön, ne Moment, können wir doch nicht weglassen, oder doch, es kompiliert doch, und wenn es kompiliert dann muss es gehen, das haben wir gelernt, schon ganz früh, sobald es kompiliert geht es auch,
was für Arbeit machst du immer bei deinem Job? Ok, das ist doch, das ist, das ist eine nice Syntax, das gefällt mir mal, ich glaube das ist die, wirklich eine der ersten neuen C++ Syntax Dinger, die ich ganz hübsch finde,
Auto, Discard, ich meine noch hübscher wäre es natürlich so, wenn es so einen Discard Operator geben würde, einen Discord Operator, einen Discard Operator, da gibt es vielleicht sowas, aha, Moment es gibt Ausrufezeichen Beruf und Ausrufezeichen Arbeit,
der Sebaro hat wieder ganze Arbeit geleistet hier,
Alter Text ey, die erste Hälfte vom Text ist ja noch nice, ist Release Manager für neue Version und kontrolliert alle Pull-Request, um denen auf den Sack zu gehen, die ihn Mist comitten, ein Clip, der ist ausführlicher erklärt, aber im Kern hat es das Sebaro ganz gut getroffen, ja.
Ich kenne meine CMD, meine Commands überhaupt nicht, ok, also wir haben jetzt einen Hintergrund-Task, der nichts anderes macht, außer sinnlos loopen, das ist natürlich reichlich sinnlos an der Stelle,
deswegen müssen wir diesen Background-Task jetzt mal was sinnvolles machen lassen, nämlich wir connecten uns erstmal zum WLAN,
Moment Schwert,
so, genau,
dann connecten wir uns mal zum WLAN,
wir sind mal ordentlich diesmal, wir machen auch hier Void,
connect,
ich werde weiter angeschrieben,
was soll das hier, EL, EL in 2019,
es ist komplett overrated eigentlich, so, was ist das für ein OS, das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM,
ok,
da müssen wir erstmal noch include, und zwar, wobei müssen wir das überhaupt include,
ok, und jetzt connecten wir uns zu meinem WLAN, und dazu müssen wir erstmal die Secrets-Datei einbinden,
weil da habe ich meine WLAN-Credentials hinterlegt, in der Hoffnung, dass ich sie nicht im Stream leake,
ok, iFile, connect, ne, Begin, Begin ist es, Begin, Begin, fuck, wie habe ich das genannt, SSID, WLAN,
oh fuck, wie habe ich den Kram genannt,
ich kann es jetzt nicht aufmachen, wenn ich es jetzt aufmache, dann sieht es jeder,
ich starte mal kurz neu hier den Ding, ja, ich kann OBS ausmachen, ich weiß,
aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich vergessen habe, wie ich den Kram genannt habe,
ich muss das irgendwas mit SSID genannt haben, alles andere wäre doch total bescheuert, oder was mit WLAN,
oder WLAN, iFile, warum kann ich mir das nicht, ok Leute, ich muss euch mal kurz umschalten auf eine andere Szene,
dass ihr mein WLAN-Passwort nicht seht, Moment, ihr seht doch immer noch was, oder, kann das sein,
so, jetzt ist weg, oh man, ey, ich habe es fast richtig, richtig geschrieben,
ich habe es fast richtig geschrieben, WLAN-SSID heißt es, und außerdem bin ich auch richtig bescheuert,
und zwar, ich schalte euch mal wieder um, es ist erstens WLAN-SSID, und zweitens muss ich einfach sagen,
secrets, muss ich erstmal ein neues secrets-Objekt anlegen, dass das funktioniert, secrets, secrets, so, und jetzt geht das nämlich auch,
ok, ich hoffe, da liegt es nicht, wenn man drüber geht, ha, nice, SSID, secrets, Passwort, Channel,
ei, wobei es eigentlich egal ist, das habe ich automatisch überlegt, so, und, oh, wo ist jetzt das Problem,
ach so, ah, der will C-Strings haben, ha, kann das sein, dass er C-Strings haben will,
also, wenn ich so mache, geht es wahrscheinlich, ne, ah, der will C-Strings haben, das ist aber Müll,
jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich, hoff ich mal, ist zwar nicht schön, ist zwar nicht schön, aber hoffentlich funktioniert es,
ok, so, jetzt sagen wir eben, warte bis WLAN verbunden ist, wait for connection reset,
also, was man sonst oft sieht, ist diese Geschichte hier, while true, not connected, bei mir geht es connecten so schnell,
dass in der Regel, wenn man hier kurz wartet, dann ist er auch connected, und wenn nicht, starten wir eh neu,
ne, wenn nicht machen wir das mal gar nichts, so, dann lassen wir uns die IP ausgeben und schauen, ob der Kram funzt,
ok, upload, warte, also, dein Main OS ist Manjaro und du streamst aus der Windows VM, ne, umgedreht, umgedreht,
ich baue mal kurz den Delay rein, umgedreht, ich streame von Windows aus und hab ne Manjaro VM, das ist deutlich einfacher,
ok, WLAN connection funzt, haben's gesehen, hier, IP, 107, 107, WLAN ist connected, ja, passt, start background task,
wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp, wieso entwickelst du eigentlich auf Linux, wegen diesem i3 Zeug,
warum soll ich nicht auf Linux entwickeln, und entwickeln unter Linux ist viel angenehmer als unter Windows,
es sei dann, es ist Bristol Studio und.NET, allein schon, wie oft die USB Verbindung rumrutscht,
unter Windows, dass ich den Controller ausstöpseln muss und wieder einstöpseln muss,
so, und jetzt können wir ja mal probieren, ich hab die Kommentar gelöscht, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie was die 10.000 hier stehen,
so, und jetzt können wir ja mal probieren, hier was Sinnvolles drin zu machen, also als erstes hören wir mal auf,
alle paar Sekunden die Distanz auszugeben, das ist ziemlich beknackt, das kann man minimieren,
und die Schleife hier so ist auch nicht sonderlich, nicht sonderlich sinnig, hier drinnen machen wir jetzt unsere MQTT Connection
und gucken, ob da Kram funktioniert, dazu brauchen wir erstmal eine MQTT Library,
und zwar dafür verwende ich immer die hier, den pubs subclient, install to, meine Projektnamen werden auch immer besser,
Projekt Omega Lul, stack size in words, ok, stack size muss ich angeben, 10.000 sollte für den bisschen Fuzz Code da reichen,
ok, jetzt haben wir den pubs subclient, und nun müssten wir ihm sagen, gegen welchen MQTT Server wir uns connecten wollen,
und zwar wir wollen gegen den Demoserver von den Jungs hier, gegen den da wollen wir uns connecten, und wir können überprüfen,
das ist ein öffentlicher MQTT Server, den würde ich normalerweise für kein Projekt verwenden, das ist bloß zum testen ganz gut,
so, wir suchen uns jetzt mal ein eigenes Topic, Streamzor ist unser Namespace quasi, und da lauschen wir jetzt mal dran,
wir gucken erstmal generell, ob da was reinkommt, ok, ok, ja gut, es ist ein öffentlicher MQTT Server, da muss man sich nicht wundern,
was da alles reinkommt, spam dann erstmal, für was die Leute das einfach schon alles wieder verwenden,
Sensors, Temperature, Total Power Sensor, was auch immer, Regenstunden am Tag, Licht an und ausschalten,
Terrassen, nicht Terrasse, Balkonswitch, Licht, Licht, Licht on, DHT Temperature Sensor, das sieht aus wie ne Windows Seriennummer,
ah Helligkeitssensor, der Typ schügt seine halbe Heimautomatisierung an öffentlichen ungeschützten MQTT Server, alles furchtbar clever,
Dead Died, Hallo Patrick, also die Leute spamen diesen Server schon, Harry Leistungsshit Port 3,
irgendwelche Livestreams, was schicken die da alles drüber, ich wills gar nicht so genau wissen, Harrys Leistungsshit,
ok, wir machen ein eigenes Topic, Streamsor, und da veröffentlichen wir jetzt was drauf, dazu müssen wir uns erstmal an diesem Server anmelden,
also include wir PubSubClient und sagen hier oben jetzt PubSubClient MQTT, warum hab ich keine Autovervollständigung,
wo ist die Autovervollständigung, rip, beenden, starten, dann geht die Autovervollständigung bestimmt, Autovervollständigung,
Global ist immer Static, ok, warum, also ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass wir hier oben angeben konnten,
den Server Name, auch ohne Autovervollständigung, den Server Name und den Port und der Port ist 1883,
ach jetzt haben wir auf einmal Autovervollständigung, ach und den WLAN Client, ok, Wi-Fi Client,
ach, also du sagst man sollte die Dinge immer Static machen, wenn der Patrick das sagt, dann machen wir das, der kennt sich aus,
warum flimmert mein Editor gerade so, das ist die Indian Hacker wieder, ok, also wir connecten uns jetzt dahin, wir brauchen jetzt noch eine Methode
über unser MQTT zum Connecten, das Ding können wir übrigens wieder löschen, das brauchen wir nicht mehr, wir brauchen jetzt noch sowas,
ich nenne das meistens Keep Alive, so irgendwie MQTT Keep Alive, brauchen wir und das ist relativ simpel, wir sagen einmal MQTT Loop,
das hält die Verbindung offen und sollte, also das hier gibt zurück, Verbindung steht, Verbindung steht nicht, wenn die Verbindung nicht steht,
dann sagen wir Connect, ich mach da gleich noch ein If drum, dann sagen wir Connect, in dem Fall müssen wir uns eine Client-ID ausdenken, mit der wir uns connecten, also nennen wir die einfach mal Random-ID
oder deine, nee, MonkaS, MonkaX ist unsere ID, connecten wir uns und dann müssen wir schauen, hat das Connecten funktioniert, wenn das Connecten funktioniert hat,
dann schreiben wir einfach mal auf die Konsole, nee Quatsch, wir machen das anders, wenn das Connecten nicht funktioniert hat, dann schreiben wir einfach auf die Konsole
ConnectionFailed, ConnectionFailed, ConnectionFailed und wenn ConnectionFailed ist, dann geben wir auch noch mit aus, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie das ging,
der konnte nämlich den ReturnCode anzeigen, was schief gegangen ist und wenn wir uns nicht connecten können, dann sind wir ganz traurig und restarten uns,
nee, wir returnen einfach, genau, wenn das Connecten funktioniert hat, dann sagen wir einfach alive,
also das sollten wir vielleicht noch hier reinschreiben, oder gucken, ob ich das if richtig hinkriege, nee, das ergibt keinen Sinn, wenn Loop nicht erfolgreich,
dann connecten, ergibt das Sinn, was ich hier gerade mache, also das heißt quasi, wenn disconnected und Connect nicht funktioniert hat, dann zeigen wir eine Fehlermeldung an,
nee, das ist richtig, das ist doch richtig, wie ich es gemacht habe, wenn nicht connected und ConnectionFailed geschlagen, dann will ich eine Fehlermeldung anzeigen,
oder, binary logic, null, du willst doch nicht jedes Mal connecten, nee, aber ich connecte doch auch nicht jedes Mal, Loop gibt false zurück, wenn es nicht connected ist,
so führt doch jedes, macht er das ernsthaft, nee, macht er nicht, achso, Moment, Moment, ja doch, nee, nee, Moment, Moment, Loop ist false,
also mal angenommen, er ist connected, er ist connected, dann ist es true und das hier wird false, dann wird das hier erst gar nicht ausgeführt, doch, das stimmt, das stimmt, doch, das stimmt, nee,
warum wird nicht beides ausgeführt, sobald das erste false ist, wird das zweite nicht mehr ausgeführt, es sei denn, es sei denn, das ist in C++ anders, wird mich aber wundern, wenn das erste false ist, wird das zweite nicht mehr ausgeführt,
weil das kann nie wieder true sein, nähe, wenn es connected ist, gibt das true und dadurch, dass da ein Not davor ist, gibt es false, ich bin mir aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so 100% sicher, ob das stimmt, was ich da jetzt gerade gebastelt habe,
ich glaube, ich glaube in C++ gibt es nur die Geschichte mit, dass das immer aufhört und dass das und quasi auch nicht weitermacht, wenn das erste true ist und sowas, und ist binary end,
aber es gibt, es gibt Sprachen, wo das so ist, mich würd's nicht wundern, ganz ehrlich, mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn es in JavaScript sowas gibt, also gibt's nicht, aber mich würd's in JavaScript nicht wundern,
in JavaScript Logik wäre das dann 0 binary end mit 0 end 0 binary end 0, das wäre JavaScript Logik, wenn man sowas schreibt, in JavaScript funktioniert fast alles,
also glaubt mir nicht, was ich erzähle, das ist vollkommen der Bullshit, das funktioniert natürlich in JavaScript auch nicht, aber was in JavaScript funktioniert, ist, das hab ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gezeigt, mal gucken, ob ich's finde,
ja, aber was in JavaScript funktioniert, ist, das hier, das funktioniert sonst in keiner anderen Sprache,
was kommt da raus, ich hab's schon ein paar Mal gezeigt, wahrscheinlich wissen Sie die meisten, die öfters gucken, was kommt da raus in JavaScript, ich, ich fühl's jetzt einfach mal aus,
und das ist sowas, das funktioniert nur in JavaScript, so Zeug, das eklig ist, in anderen Sprachen kannst du was gar nicht machen, da kommt raus, es ist, es ist JavaScript, ja,
sowas geht nur in JavaScript, gut, so kleiner Einschub, so, wir, wir connecten uns, das heißt, wir machen jetzt hier unsere Endlosschleife, ja, das hab ich auch aus einem Vortrag, das hab ich mir nicht selbst ausgedacht,
das hab ich, das hab ich aus einem Vortrag, okay, und hier drinnen rufen wir jetzt die
MQTT connect geschickt, keepalive, Funktion auf, und schauen wir mal, was passiert, ob das keepalive auf dem zweiten Core funktioniert,
Serial, alive, alive, alive, alive, okay, scheint zu funktionieren, okay, dann können wir jetzt ja auch mal sagen, NQTT publish, publish, wir publishen was auf dieses Topic, gucken, ob es ankommt,
jedes Sekunde, Topic ist Streamzor, und Message ist, du hast zwei Cores, ja, ich hab zwei Cores mit 240MHz, Pock, eigentlich sogar drei Cores, zwei Cores mit 240MHz und ein low power Prozessor mit 8MHz,
so, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, der publish nichts, feels Batman, Moment, der hat gar nicht kompiliert, weil ich einen Sonntagsfehler hab, was ist das, das ist eine ESP32,
ESP32 Note MCU, das ist ein Entwicklerboard mit einem ESP32 drauf, der ESP32 ist eh ziemlich nett, du warst doch im Stream dabei letztens, wo wir uns das eingeschaut haben,
guck mal, die haben noch viel mehr als zwei Cores, die sind richtig nice, die haben, die haben zwei, zwei und drei, das sind zwei und drei Spitcores, das sind zwei, zwei und drei Spitcores, du hast einen ultra low power Prozessor mit 8MHz,
du hast RAM, oder, naja, nicht wirklich, ja doch, du hast Memory, wo beide drauf zugreifen können, also die überleben auch einen Deep Sleep und was richtig nice ist, du hast Hardware Beschleunigung für AES und RSA
und einen Hardware Beschleunigung, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es einen Hardware Beschleunigten Random Number Generator gibt, genau, aber jetzt ist das, die Dinger sind recht cool und sie haben Bluetooth und WLAN drauf,
Bluetooth, WLAN und können die üblichen Sachen ansprechen, also du hast einen I2C Bus, du hast einen SPI Bus, du kannst PWM machen für irgendwelche Lüfter und Gedöns und Pulsgeschichten,
du hast einen Touch Sensor, den habe ich schon nie verwendet, den Temperature Sensor habe ich auch noch nie verwendet, du hast, ich glaube, zehn Analog zu Digital Converter und du hast irgendwie so einen Fake Digital Analog Converter,
wo ich nicht so genau checke, wie der funktioniert, aber das ist richtig huge, was da dabei ist.
Läuft das Hardware Rad, ach guck mal hier, er veröffentlicht übrigens, Pog, huge Pog, Pepega, oh Leute, jetzt sind die ersten schon am Spam hier,
das ist ja witzig, ja auf weiter Spam, Leute, omg Leute,
Ricky ist nicht da heute, ne, guck mal mal wieder aus, ok, also das Publishing funktioniert, was wir hier machen,
ich glaube, wenn wir das hier ohne machen, da kriegen wir,
das funktioniert schon mal, also das MQTT Publishing auf dem zweiten Core klappt wunderbar, also jetzt könnten wir eigentlich sagen, wir lesen auf dem ersten Core, lesen wir Werte ein,
jetzt haben wir die Auswahl, also jetzt haben wir die Auswahl, was wir machen, wir können, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal überlegen,
wir könnten entweder die Noob Variante benutzen, wir machen eine globale Variable, wo beide Cores darauf zugreifen können
und schreiben dort vom ersten Core die Sensordaten rein und vom zweiten Core lesen wir die Sensordaten und publishen sie,
oder aber wir machen irgendwie einen Stack oder eine Queue oder sowas, schreiben die Werte rein und lesen sie dann vom anderen Core aus,
allerdings müssen wir der Queue ein Limit geben, sonst, weil der erste Core, je nachdem, wie wir den machen, der ist wahrscheinlich deutlich schneller mit Auslesen,
wie der zweite mit Abarbeiten, ja, ein Ring Buffer wäre tatsächlich am besten, dass wir nicht Stuck sind mit alten Werten irgendwie, ja, ich habe aber keine Ahnung, ob ein Ring Buffer dabei ist mit dem Badoino Zeug.
Circular Buffer, ne, ich bastle jetzt nichts eigenes, ach da, guck mal, du weißt doch, ich bin der Low Level Noob, ich mach sowas nicht,
Stream Buffer-Example, ja, genau, der Patrick kann uns sowas ja machen und auf Pastebin posten, dann verwenden wir das auch,
aber die haben eine Queue, mit einer Queue ist das auch nice, XQ Create, ja, poste mal, ich finde das nice, wenn wir den einen oder anderen Viewer Code verwenden,
oh, der Serious Max ist da, den Derp, wie funktioniert das mit einer Queue, gibt es da vielleicht Examples für, XQ Create, Sample, Sample, aha, ok, das sieht eigentlich ziemlich easy aus,
eine Queue mit 10 Plätzen drin, ach, ich finde das sieht eigentlich ganz, ganz brauchbar aus, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus,
und danach verwenden wir den Ringbuffer von Patrick, das probieren wir jetzt erstmal aus, ok, das heißt im Setup Background Task,
ne, im Setup, wir wissen ja nicht, was zuerst läuft, im Setup legen wir mal sowas hier an, ja Patrick, keine Hektik, keine Ahnung, so, wir machen mal eine globale Variable mit Q1,
Q, cool, so, so, aber ganz am Anfang, dass ich es dann noch wieder finde, so, und wir brauchen einen Size Of, einen Size Of, ja, keine Ahnung,
einen, eine Ahnung, einen Int, einen Int, 32, so, klopseln wir da einfach rein, da können wir, da kriegen wir dann 4 Characters drinne unter,
immerhin, ja, das reicht für unseren POC, schau mal aus, ok, Q Create, und jetzt muss man was machen hier drinnen, dann, und jetzt sagt man dann,
wie geht das weiter, X, Q, N, Q oder sowas, N, Q, N, Q, ne, Add To Set, Add To Create, Add To Set, ne, Q Send,
wir gucken uns mal ein vollständiges Beispiel an, ja, Tutorials gucken, Send, ist das ok, ah ja, Create, Send, ah ja,
weil, aber das ist doch doof,
warum funktioniert das überhaupt so, weil ich mein, Value gibt's nicht mehr im nächsten Durchlauf, oder kopiert da sich das Intern in die Q,
der wird sich das Intern in die Q kopieren, der geht zu der Speicheradresse, nimmt sich den Value raus und kopiert das Intern in die Q,
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, Ticks To Made, ok, was auch immer, das machen wir jetzt mal, und dann sagen wir Q Receive,
und das posten wir dann per MQTT an den Server, und Element, also muss man sagen, Int, Element, 0, dann wird das überschrieben mit dem anderen,
denke ich mal, ja, und dann posten wir das, oh, ist unendlich warten bis Platz ist, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht,
dann bleibt er einfach hängen, so eigentlich ganz cool, dann bleibt er, wobei, egal, wir probieren das jetzt erst mal aus,
Moment, was hat er für Schmerzen? Achso, weil das kein String ist, wie macht man einen ordentlichen Int zu String?
Ok, so schauen wir mal nicht, wie macht man denn, das ist eine gute Frage, macht man denn Int zu einem Arduino String?
Google Beste, hier wird mit Cortana programmiert, oh, das müssen wir auch demnächst wieder, wir müssen auch demnächst wieder,
was, to Int, das ist String to Int, sowas wie to Str, String to Int, nein, wir wollen Int to String, String to Int,
Load und Int to String, was, da muss man ordentlich fertige Funktionen für geben,
aber was wahrscheinlich geht, ich glaube der C++ Standard String hat einen Konstruktor, der einen Int nimmt, oder?
Alter C++ fuckt mich jetzt nicht ab, Auto Convert String to Load, nein, das funktioniert, das glaube ich, dass das funktioniert,
das soll funktionieren, das glaube ich nicht, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert,
das Programm, womit ich die Emotes einplende, da gibt es eine uralt Version auf GitHub, das funktioniert ernsthaft,
das ist ja die beknacktesten Int to String Konvertierungen, die ich je gesehen habe,
ah nice, Patrik, guck ich mir klar an, erstmal muss ich eine Basic Frage klären, wie schaffe ich das, einen Int zu einem Arduino String zu machen,
ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht ob das dabei ist, das sieht easy aus, also wie funktioniert das,
so, Value ist Element, ach da muss ich jetzt erstmal einen Buffer angeben, der das macht, da muss ich schon was fertiges geben, das geht mir voll auf den Sack,
wie, das habe ich doch gerade gemacht, das habe ich doch gerade so gemacht, Moment, das habe ich doch gerade so gemacht, das ging nicht,
doch das ist das allererste was ich ausprobiert habe, das war doch das erste was ich ausprobiert habe,
debatet, ok, einetwegen, manche Sachen die checkt man nicht,
ok, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob der den Kram veröffentlicht,
aber warum, aber warum kannst du den Port nicht öffnen, ich mache mal ab und wieder an,
ok, jetzt funktioniert es, was auch immer, funktioniert 200,
Sensor, Hand rüber, ups, Hand rüber lassen vielleicht, ach so, ja meine Q ist zu schnell voll, die kommt nicht hinterher,
ja meine Q ist voll, die hat, ich erstelle die Sachen ein bisschen zu schnell,
ich erstelle, ich erstelle den Wert alle 10 mal in der Sekunde und verschicke den Wert plus alle, das ist nicht so sinnvoll,
ich mach das mal jemals pro Sekunde, ja Patrick ich guck mich das gleich an,
ich muss das erstmal hier fertig machen, ich guck mir gleich deinen krassen Ring-Buffer an, ja jetzt funktioniert es,
ok, der Patrick hat uns was geschickt, das sieht ja richtig ordentlich aus,
und da soll ich checken, was der macht oder wie, also,
du schickst ein paar Inns an,
sind das hier Labels oder so, oder ist das einfach, das benutzt man für Write, das benutzt man für Read und das im Setup,
ach so, ok, Reply Error, ok Leute, probieren wir das mal aus,
Interactive Code Copy Pasting,
Agile, Agile Copy Pasting,
und jetzt zum reinschreiben nimmt man das da, muss mir da mal kurz angucken was da eigentlich passiert, ok die Que lassen wir mal weg,
haben wir jetzt eigentlich ordentlich Format, was denn hier kaputt,
nothing failed, see Output Window, Output, super,
Fehlermeldung, ok, gut hier muss ich einfach irgendwas printen,
das Return kann ich mir eh sparen, weil wir sind ja nicht in der Funktion, wir sind ja in der Main Loop drinnen,
muss ich das da in Ls packen, wenn ich da kein Return rein mache,
ok, anderes Output Window, JIT, C++ Omega Lul,
LipTinfo Cannot Open Shared Object File, das klingt als hätte ich irgendwas nicht installiert dafür, dass es funktioniert, der ist hammer gleich,
you need to install Ncurses 5 Combat Lips,
ja dann installieren wir das doch einfach mal, Ncurses 5 Combat Lips, 507 Sterne, das ist ja glaube ich die meistgestarteste User Repo was ich in letzter Zeit so gesehen habe,
oh no, wir gucken uns das nicht an, wir installieren das jetzt einfach blind,
das könnte ja auch viel zu einfach sein, no, Skip, Signature,
wir machen das ohne PGP, ja, Skip PGP Check, YOLO,
wie skipt man den Mist, war ich doch schon,
Alter Gbaited, Gbaited,
mal gucken ob da irgendwelche anderen Leute schon Probleme reingeschrieben haben,
gibt,
das haben wir doch jetzt, das haben wir schon 85 mal da dran gehängt, das bringt ja nichts,
findet nichts, ok dann fügen wir einfach die Keys von dem Dude hinzu,
und dann gehts hoffentlich,
das ist eh die bessere Lösung, nicht einfach den Check skippen, sondern einfach den Key von dem Typ der das Repo angelegt hat hinzufügen,
das ist eigentlich auch die richtige Lösung, die haben wir mal ordentlich gelöst, Sachen gibts, eine Runde compilen,
Compiler Output Weste, aber ich finde die C++ Projekte die teilweise mit, wie heißt das, ja ist dieses Make System da,
das was so schöne Prozentangaben und bunte Terminal Ausgaben macht, das finde ich viel schöner,
das ist so Raw AC Build mit CSC Make, mit Auto Make, ja kann sein, das wo Boost auch mit gebildet wird,
das ist auch immer schön bunt wenn Boost gebildet wird, ok kann ich das jetzt formatieren,
so und was machst du als nächstes hier, Read, ok kompiliert das noch das was wir hier haben,
so und jetzt mach ich was, jetzt Publish ich hier drin oder was oder wie oder wo oder was,
aber dann mach ich das Delay noch mal hier rein, macht das überhaupt Sinn zu Delayen, ok also machen wir das so,
jetzt, ok gucken wir uns mal was der Patrick da gebastelt hat, ob das funktioniert,
was ist jetzt mit dem Board schon wieder ey, wo ist das Problem,
wo ich sollte Netze lernen und bin irgendwie auf Twitch gelandet, das passiert mir auch öfters,
dass ich irgendwie auf irgendwas suche auf Twitch und dann irgendwo hängen bleibe und nicht das
was ich eigentlich machen sollte, der Publish nichts, Moment ich schreibe ja auch überhaupt nichts rein,
der schreibe ja auch überhaupt nichts rein, mit 1 schreibe ich rein, aber der Publish nichts,
der Publish nichts, aber der Publish nichts, dann gucken wir mal was der mir sagt,
den Kram ausgebe, Connecting bla bla bla,
kann das sein, dass der hängt, kann das sein, dass der hängt, achso,
vergiss es Patrick, ich hab das Receive noch drinnen, ich hab das Receive noch drinnen,
ich hab das Receive noch drinnen, jetzt funktioniert es, jetzt funktioniert es,
ich versuche gerade ein bisschen Multithreading mit einem ESP32, jetzt funktioniert es auch,
wo schreibt man den Wert rein, hier, ne, das ist mir zu advanced C-Hexor Style,
wo schreibt man, ne hier unten, ah Wahl, so oder, ja ESP32 sehr nice,
ich meine Dual, Multithreading ist komplett overkill für das was ich gerade mache,
ich will es einfach mal ausprobieren, oh ist schön, nice, easy, ok, dann stellen wir das
mal ein bisschen hoch, alle 100 Millisekunden und alle 100 Millisekunden,
hier kann er ruhig so lang publishen, wie was in der queue ist, ist das ok,
dann machen wir das mal auf dieser Loop noch mal drumherum, nice, kommt es euch an,
ich frage übrigens jetzt ganz glaube ich ein bisschen zu schnell ab,
ich hoffe wir fragen den Sensor gerade ein bisschen schnell ab, dem gefällt das nicht,
also das ist auch thread safe, also aus Bauch an würde ich sagen aktuell schon,
Sachen sind eigentlich fast immer thread safe, wenn du nur von einer Stelle reinschreibst,
aber wir sind glaube ich ein bisschen zu, das ist ein bisschen zu viel für den Sensor,
hier müssen wir ein bisschen mehr Zeit lassen, machen wir mal 500 Millisekunden,
es ist ja nicht so das es nicht reichen würde, ich will das normalerweise alle halbe Stunde
einmal machen, in der Regel ist eigentlich der meiste Code, wenn man ein bisschen
darüber Gedanken macht, ist eigentlich defaultmäßig thread safe, wenn du irgendeine queue hast
oder irgendwas, wo nur eine Sache schreiben kann, dann ist es eigentlich fast egal,
es geht eigentlich, die Sachen wo es Probleme gibt, ist eigentlich meistens nur, wenn du
versuchst auf eine Ressource, also Ressource kann alles mögliche sein, eine Variable,
irgendwas, wenn du auf eine Ressource versuchst mit gleichzeitig zwei Sachen zu schreiben,
dann gibt es eigentlich meistens Probleme, wenn du, wie gesagt meistens außerhalb besteht
die Regel, wenn du dich dran hältst, dass du mit einer Sache schreibst und mit beliebig
Least gibt es meistens keine Probleme. Funktioniert gut, Leute das funktioniert echt
nice, ein sehr, sehr nice, ein sehr, sehr nice Waffergeschichte, die der Patrick hier gebastelt
hat, bin ich nice, das gefällt mir, das ist so richtig, das ist so typisch C-Hexor-Gedöns,
alles, alles bloß nicht ausschreiben, Tifo in index, aber das gefällt mir, ich meine
das ist, also für C ist das wirklich ordentlich, was er hier, also vom Style ist das wirklich
gut gemacht, da verstehst du, verstehst du alles, das ist ja Poggi. So Leute wir machen
jetzt schon Schluss, es ist zwar früher als sonst, aber wieder bin ich schon überhaupt
schon on, aber ich muss jetzt noch ein paar Sachen machen, ja nur zwei Stunden heute,
das, aber dafür, besser nur zwei Stunden und dafür regelmäßig Streams anstatt wieder
lang Pause oder, ich muss jetzt noch ein paar Sachen erledigen und dann müsste ich eh 21
Uhr Stream ausmachen, dass ich dann wieder pennen kann, morgen 5.45 Uhr aufstehen, ich
hoffe, ich hoffe es klappt morgen wieder mit weiterem Stream, der Sayumi Staubsauger ist
jetzt im Angebot, habe ich gelesen, vorhin schon auf Twitter und das war dann schon ausverkauft,
Discord, Discord ich gucke es mir nachher, ich gucke es mir nachher an, ich muss jetzt
erst mal was erledigen, zum Angebot, wird der immer teurer, vorhin hat er nur 340 gekostet,
ja das ist abgelaufen, das ist abgelaufen, ok Leute ich muss jetzt weg, wir sehen uns
morgen, machts gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, CU.